[Musique]
au début des bulles comme mon père
commencé depuis 45 ans et à les choisir
dans le pâturage
je suis veuf là il à l'herbe ou lennar
musclé il a l'air en santé avec les
années l'achat de la viande de boeuf a
bien changé le boucher nicolas sévelin
peut maintenant choisir des bêtes par
textos chez des fournisseurs locaux
donc maintenant ils m'envoient des
photos carrément oncogènes un beau
spécimen pour tours moi ce que j'aime
c'est quand on voit les muscles
carrément là dessus pour lui c'est la
seule façon de savoir exactement d'où
provient sa viande
mais la forte demande pour certaines
coupes l'obligent à fermer à faire avec
d'autres fournisseurs
quand les gens partent sur l'onglet de
boeuf c'est l'onglet de boeuf qu'ils
veulent c'est pas de la bavette c'est
pas autre chose c'est langue de boeuf
donc les fous je réponde à la clientèle
mais deux anglais de boeuf que g par
semaine ça suffit pas à la demande
on lâche obligé d'acheter ailleurs
résultat la boucherie doit acheter des
pièces de boeuf qui peuvent pas revenir
du canada mais aussi des états unis et
peut être même meilleur
est-ce que je connais la traçabilité je
peux vous dire qu'il est peau qu'il est
bon mais je sais pas si ça a été levée
dans tel wrench sais pas s'il a passé
toute sa vie au canada j'en ai aucune
idée aucune des pièces qu'on sait s'ils
sont élevés
de la même façon aux états unis qu'au
canada
une idée
c'est quoi votre priorité comme
magasiner votre viande hachée c'est de
prendre des produits du québec
vraiment les consommateurs veulent de
plus en plus savoir ce qu'il mange
oui le prix est une priorité mais la
provenance les méthodes de production ou
d'élevage figure parmi les premiers
critères d'achat mais pour le boeuf
cette information est presque impossible
à trouver en épicerie mais le c'est
écrit clairement produit du canada
donc en principe ça devrait 100 %
canadien n'y a pas de garantie est
absolument rien qui nous dit si 100%
canadien élevé 100 % canadien de la
naissance jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à la
finition buzz canada on veut dire quoi
par boeuf canada est ce que c'est un
boeuf né au canada
lg au canada a battu au canada qu'est ce
qu'on entend pas bof canada
marie-christine talbot spécialiste en
traçabilité tout comme notre boucher ont
de bonnes raisons de se poser toutes ces
questions puisque l'agencé canadienne
d'inspection des aliments autorise la
mention produit du canada même si le
boeuf n'a passé que 60 jours au pays
sur 500 jours de vie en moyenne la bête
peut être né au canada engraisser aux
états unis et a battu ici les grades
canada 3 à ou canada numéro un ne sont
que des gages de qualité ou des profs
d'inspection et de salubrité
pourquoi si c'est si compliqué de nous
d'où proviennent le devient oui la
question habile dollars en fait toute la
première portion un animal voix et
identifiés individuellement encaissés
comme un numéro d'assurance sociale qui
suit toute sa vie à partir de l'abattoir
ça devient des lots produits donc un lot
peut être constituée d'une demi journée
ou d'une journée d'abattage et il peut y
avoir en provenance de différentes
fermes de différents animaux et après ça
c'est lola sont revendus et remixé à dr
donc c'est là qu'on peut perdre la
traçabilité de l'animal au départ
l'américain ken guile et le brésilien
jbs sont les deux plus gros joueurs de
l'industrie
il achète tout et partout au québec
canada etats unis mexique
ils revendent sur le marché des viandes
qui n'ont plus vraiment de nationalité
seule certitude c'est que 75% du boeuf
que l'on consomme provient de l'amérique
du nord
le reste provient de l'amérique du sud
et même de l'océanie
quand on constitue par exemple une boîte
de filet de boeuf de deux filets par
burr sacrum beaucoup d'animaux pour
arriver à faire cette droite là donc
beaucoup d'animaux veut dire beaucoup de
provenance de différentes classes et
aucun règlement n'oblige l'industrie
affiché une provenance sur l'emballage
dommage puisque le boeuf canadien a une
grande réputation
mais difficile de se le procurer avec
certitude pour répondre à la demande de
boeuf local la société des parcs
d'engraissement du québec a créé la
marque boeuf québec en collaboration
avec le distributeur viande lauzon et
deux abattoirs québécois à ces personnes
doivent déjà en place justement pour
nous permettre d'avoir notre propre
filière complète qui nous permet
d'élever nos odeurs de les transformer
ici au québec qui a en sus à bloc pour
les présenter aux québécois sont les
tablettes avec
garantis que c'est un produit québécois
100 % québécois pas tout à fait la
véritable garantie et que le boeuf a
passé au moins 100 jours où québec
c'est une décision de partir ça pour pas
donner trop de contraintes aux éleveurs
et aux producteurs juste pour saisir on
part avec un certain une certaine norme
il ya beaucoup de travail qui est fait
ce qu'on veut naturellement c'est
d'avoir 100% des boeufs qui sont nés au
québec les québécois veulent seul et
consommant soir valls a de toute façon
c'est la prochaine étape nous heavy rain
le boeuf haché bluff québec
oui oui mais je n'ai jamais acheté celui
là est ce qu'il ya vraiment une grosse
différence pour de l'autre
mais je les sers et là où on essaie de
tout est au taux de 5 10% au-dessus de 2
d'un prix moyen puis on sait si le défi
de façon à ce que le consommateur soit
pas de taxi j'irai dans son dans son
désir de signer lundi le calme neuf
québec s'inspire de alberta beef ou
encore de boeuf canada ces deux marques
ne peuvent pas non plus nous garantir du
boeuf 100% local comme le prétend leur
publicité
[Musique]
si vous voulez du boeuf 100% local les
fermes valence en vente chez métro ou
encore les viandes un talent sont permis
les seuls à vous offrir cette garantie
en épicerie également les producteurs de
bovins du québec ont mis en place un
portail pour trouver un éleveur dans
votre région
enfin vous pouvez aussi faire confiance
en eux boucher président de monsieur
bourassa lui et les travaux dans les
cantons de l'est
en travaillant avec des éleveurs direct
ça pour moi c'est fabuleux
[Musique]